AT LEAST GIVE US ALONE.
ED, FANTASTICAL PART.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME
RIGHT NOW HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
STEVE SCALISE AND CONGRESSMAN
SCALISE, I KNOW YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE AOC LURCH TO THE
LEFT OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY BUT
SCHUMER AND PELOSI LOVE TO SAY
TRUMP THROWS TEMPER TANTRUMS
SO THEY SAY HE IS PETULANCE.
HE WALKED OUT OF THE MEETING.
WHAT DOES THIS LOOK LIKE?
>> LAURA, THE LEFT HAS BECOME
UNHINGED.
I'VE BEEN IN ALL THOSE MEETINGS
IN THE SITUATION ROOM WITH
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER,
TOP LEADERS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
EVERYTHING THE MEETING, THE
PRESIDENT WAS NOT ONLY COLD BUT
HE WAS PUTTING OPTIONS ON THE
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT W
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT I
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT E
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT S
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT C
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT R
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT N
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT G
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT T
TABLE TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT E
BORDER.
NOT ONE SINGLE TIME DID THEY
EVER PUT AN ALTERNATIVE ON THE
TABLE.
NOT ONCE.
SO THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
ALMOST 30 DAYS NOW.
THE PRESIDENT WAS THERE DURING
CHRISTMAS WAITING.
HE'S THERE NOW.
HE'S BEEN TALKING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND FRANKLY
YOU'RE SEEN THE POLLING GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER AS PEOPLE FIND
OUT --
>> Laura: THEY WANT TO RIDE IT
OUT.
SHE THINKS HE CAN RIDE THIS ALL
THE WAY TO GETTING TRUMP TO
CAVE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE TRUMP'S NO
NEW TAXES MOAN.
I SAID YOU WERE HOUSE MINOR
LEADER.
>> REPUBLICAN WHIP.
>> Laura: WHIPPING THOSE VOTES
VOTES.
SHE THINKS IS THE GOOD FOR HER
POLITICALLY.
ALL THE CROCODILE TEARS ABOUT
THE WORKERS AND THEY ARE HANGING
OUT IN PUERTO RICO BUT THE
WORKERS -- EVERY DIFFICULT STORY
OF A WORKER NOT BEING ABLE TO
PAY FOR A BILL.
EVERY SINGLE STORY IS SHOWING
UP.
IT'S A DRUMBEAT AND THE
PRESSURES ON THE PRESIDENT.
THEY NEED TO PUT THE PRESSURE ON
THE PRESIDENT TO CAVE.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
CAVING.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
STEADFAST AND CONSISTENT IN
SAYING THAT HE IS GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING IT TAKES TO SECURE
AMERICA'S BORDER.
HE'S POINTED OUT JUST HOW BAD
THE PROBLEMS ARE.
LOOK, LAURA, THIS LATEST DON'T
AND IT'S NOT EVEN A STUNT.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE ON INVITING
A PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK SHE'S
GOING TO TURN HER BACK?
I PREDICT THERE ARE SOME IN THIS
PROGRESSIVE NEW CAUCUS WILL TURN
THEIR BACK IF THAT PRESIDENT
WALKED DOWN THE AISLE.
>> THEY HAVE TRIED TO DO
EVERYTHING TO INSULT THE
PRESIDENT, IT'S NOT EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HE IS THE
PRESIDENT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW THE FACTS
ABOUT THIS.
THEY WANT TO WATCH.
THEY'VE BEEN TUNING IN.
THEY WATCHED LAST WEEKEND THEY
SAW SCHUMER AND PELOSI GIVE THAT
RIDICULOUS LOOKING RESPONSE.
I THINK THEY ARE SAYING THAT IT
IS STARTING TO COME UNHINGED ON
THEIR SIDE WHEN YOU SEE MORE
DEMOCRATS, MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
GETTING REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE THEY ARE SEEN
PEOPLE NOT GET PAYCHECKS AND
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEIR
PARTY'S STANDING UP FOR OPEN
BORDERS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SECURE THE
BORDER.
THAT'S AN UNTENABLE POSITION TO
HOLD.
TO SAY YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LET
THE PRESIDENT COME TO THE
CAPITAL TO GIVE A STATE OF THE
UNION.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT IT WAS THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
I THOUGHT SHE ALWAYS LIKED TO
SAY IT WAS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
GRANDMA MIMI WITH ALL THE
GRANDKIDS.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> THEY MIGHT BE HOLDING THE
PAYCHECKS OF GOVERNMENT WORKERS
HOSTAGE FOR NOW TO LITERALLY
HOLD THE STATE OF THE UNION
HOSTAGE, LAURA, IT'S AN
UNTENABLE POSITION.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD JUST SAM
COMING.
>> PICK ANOTHER VENUE.
GO NEAR THE BORDER.
SHOW EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON NOT
ONLY THE BORDER BUT IF YOU LIVE
IN PENNSYLVANIA, YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY WHOSE SON DIED OF AN
OVERDOSE FROM HEROIN.
90% OF THE HEROINE IS COMING
FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS PROBLEM AFFECTS EVERYBODY
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO SECURE THE BORDER.
I DON'T -- THE PELOSI CAN TRY TO
STOP THE TRUTH FROM COMING OUT.
I TALKED TO SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY NIELSEN THIS
EVENING ABOUT THIS VERY PROBLEM.
SHE SAID THE SECRET SERVICE,
THEY'VE BEEN PLANNING --
>> Laura: IT'S A LIE.
LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT IS.
THEY SAY TRUMP LIED.
THAT WAS A LIE.
SHE LIED ABOUT THAT.
>> REACHING OUT TO THEM TO FIND
OUT --
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF THE FACTS
COMING OUT.
>> Laura: CRACKS IN THE
DEMOCRAT OPPOSITION TO THE WALL.
>> THEY ARE FEELING THE HEAT.
SOME OF THESE NEW HOUSE MEMBERS
THAT AREN'T FAR LEFT LIKE AOC,
THEY ARE STARTING TO FEEL THE
PRESSURE.
THEY TRIED TO STOP SOME OF THEM
FROM GOING TO THE WHITE HOUSE
THE OTHER DAY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE CRITICIZING
CLEMSON.
THEY ARE CRITICIZING CLEMSON.
PEOPLE ARE CRITICIZING THE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL CHAMPIONS.
THIS IS STENY HOYER ON WITH
BRET BAIER TODAY ABOUT WHETHER
THE WALL IS IMMORAL.
LET'S WATCH.
>> A WALL IS IMMORAL IF IT TRIES
TO IMPRISON PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T
BE IN PRISON.
A WALL THAT PROTECTS PEOPLE IS
NOT IMMORAL.
>> Shannon: DO YOU THINK A
WALL, A BARRIER IS RACIST?
>> I DON'T TALK IN THOSE TERMS.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE WAY WE
OUGHT TO LOOK AT IT.
>> Laura: AS I SAID IN THE
ANGLE, CALLING SOMEONE OR
SOMETHING RACIST IS A WAY TO
AVOID A SUBSTANTIVE DEBATE IS,
IT'S A WEEK SISTER MOVE.
>> IT DEFIES THE GRAVITY OF
WHERE THEY WERE.
IN 2006, CHUCK SCHUMER VOTED NOT
JUST FOR STEEL SLAT BARRIERS,
CHUCK SCHUMER AND BARACK OBAMA
VOTED FOR OVER $50 BILLION.
THE PRESIDENT IS ASKING FOR
ONE-TENTH OF THAT AMOUNT.
>> Laura: I THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS TO STAY.
HE HAS TO BE A WALL OF STRENGTH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
ROCK-SOLID STANDING UP FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SECURE THE
BORDER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BY LARGE
WANT TO GET THIS DONE.
>> Laura: TELL NANCY TO DROP
HER SECURITY DETAIL AND KEEP THE
DOOR OPEN AND PACIFIC HEIGHTS OR